e e
[Music]
good evening everybody um I'm calling
the finance committee for March 10th
2025 to
order and
um there's Caleb I didn't see Caleb no
I'm sorry he has has made it yet he hit
traffic he'll be here about 610 okay I
was trying to let him go first thank you
I appreciate that no problem let me know
when he gets in here if I'm busy we the
agenda is fairly light so we'll move on
forward uh first item I have is
temporary
resolution 262 a resolution authorizing
the Langster tree commission to apply
for the Ohio Department of Natural
Resources urban forestry Grant and to
declare emergency coming from the
service committee
yeah uh Steve are you back there I
thought I saw
you good evening thank you for the
opportunity to come speak with you today
um the pre commission would like request
approval to apply for the second round
of the ODNR urban forestry grant for
amount not to exceed
$75,000 the plan is to use this for
Citywide public tree inventory and
plantings the grant is a reimbursable
grant there's no local match um required
which is very nice um staff would budget
for this dep part of the 2026 budget
process and have the work done in the
year 2026 the application opened up in
late January early February the deadline
is April 1 just to give you some
highlights on our Urban Forest we
estimate that we have 6 to 7,000 public
trees in the city city has approximately
31% canopy cover including private land
trees are these trees are estimated to
to remove 239 tons of carbon annually
and prevent 1.6 million gallons of storm
water runoff so there's significant
impact with our Urban Forest these trees
are City assets just like the roads um
the utility infrastructure Etc and
currently we have no inventory of those
assets we don't know exactly what we
have in the city we just have estimates
so an inventory um would give us the
would identify the trees the species the
locations the tree condition identify
planning locations and allow us to
manage those um trees and also put them
into the city GIS system so we would
have that that Asset Management
capability also allows us to manage our
existing Forest proactively currently
we're very reactive we get a phone call
we go deal with a tree this will give us
a chance to get ahead of the curve and
take care of both hazardous trees and
pruning ahead of the time that they
become become dangerous or a problem um
this also allows us to start working on
replac in Street trees which is a been
one of our long-term goals by
identifying planning sites and moving
forward so that is what we're asking for
is for the ability to apply for that
grant our deadline is April 1st and I'll
entertain any questions you might
have I just like to comment that one of
the things that um the mayor appointed a
committee to look at the commission and
their operation and that kind of thing
and one of the things that I I think we
all realized is that the tree Commission
has to have I mean a basic fundamental
piece of the tree commission is that you
have to have an inventory so everyone
that we look at in the central Ohio area
that we're comparing ourselves to they
started with a tree inventory and it
just seems
like the right thing to do and the right
time to do it so thank you Steve yeah I
do have a question
so I think it was last year the year
before before you came back I believe we
had a group of students there were
college students come and they had done
had had done some work for the parks I
believe um is there any way maybe we can
have that done again and maybe they
could help try to find where these are
um we did have actually I was here we
did have an intern that worked with the
gis inter and they did do some work for
us however um doing the entire city that
way would take years and years of work
and by the time we got that done why and
if there were certain places we could
focus on uh certain areas maybe I don't
know I'm just trying to think of
something to help yeah that work was
mostly done at the Arboretum right
Arboretum and also some of the uh some
of the older section of town King Street
down to the park from from Main Street I
was just throwing it out there maybe if
they could even you know other sections
that they've already done some they
could try other places I don't
know okay okay Council now if your
pleasure uh first of two readings please
okay and Michael is my second second
perfect thank you thank you thanks
Steve now we got temporary resolution
27-25 resolution authorizing the city
law director's office to apply for the
violence against women act Grant coming
from law committee uh councilman CR yes
thank you uh this is an annual piece a
legislation um that we apply for and
it's a reimbursement Grant award up to
60,000 with a 25% match and the funds
are used to offset salary and benefits
of one of the family and Dating Violence
prosecutors La director Hall is there
anything additional you'd like to add no
ma'am you covered it um I will just say
I I updated you all a couple weeks ago
on the fact that we still haven't
received our vawa award for 20125 and we
are still waiting uh for that number
they typically always give us something
we just don't know know what it is so
still waiting to see what that number is
and my hopes aren't high that we'll know
any sooner next year unfortunately but
um you know every little bit helps and
so we would like to do whatever we can
to offset that
expense thank
you um Mr bizjack will be my second and
we're going three
readings I'm sorry did you I got
interrupted here yeah you're fine and
you I your second uh Mr bis Jack my
second BJ okay good very good thank you
um we'll move on to the ordinances
temporary ordinance
14-25 an ordinance approving the the
editing and inclusion of certain
ordinances as part of the various
component codes of the codified
ordinance of Lancaster Ohio and Clare em
mergency from the law committee uh
councilman C yes thank you um we were
notified by our code publisher that
there are codes um that mirror the Ohio
Revis code that are now out of date due
to changes to the state code and we need
that to get those updated and we are
going to ask for suspension because some
of these all of them have already passed
some of them as long as 6 months ago and
we want to prevent further confusion for
law enforcement okay any questions on
the suspension or the
legislation okay and this is the one I'm
going to uh second for you correct yes
sir thank you
moving on to Temporary ordinance 15-25
an ordinance to amend permanent
ordinance
55-24 also known as The Parks and
Recreation pay ordinance and to declare
an emergency coming from service
committee councilman Al again Steve are
you still here thank
you this is going to sound a lot more
complicated than it really is but he's
got it
down um what we're requ requesting um
and this was run through Park board at
the February meeting and they did
approve it needed to come to you to talk
to it also we're basically asking to
change titles of jobs we're not asking
for any increases in Pay we're not
asking for anything that's going to have
any fiscal impact on the budget um that
was passed already so basically what
we're doing during the budget process we
had a retirement that was unexpected
that gave us an opportunity to take a
look at the pay ordinance and the titles
um and we have to recruit for that
position now it was the facility
supervisor position um it was already
paid at a higher rate than the other two
supervisor positions the parks
department has three supervisors
facility Recreation and Senior Services
olivedale we're basically asking to take
one of those supervisor positions turn
it into an assistant superintendent
position and reclass the other two
supervisor positions is strictly
supervisors that we assign to a a work
area this allows us two things one it
gives us a broader recruitment for that
position the position was already
basically functioning as an assistant
superintendent when when I when I was
not here they approved payroll they
approved purchasing they did all the
work that that I would do if I were if I
was here um so there was that piece U
position like I said was already paid at
a higher pay range um they'll still
oversee one of the three program areas
in the department and they'll have
oversight over the other two um by
changing the two supervisor positions to
just supervisor resid in specific
program areas that also allows internal
candidates the opportunity to apply for
the assistant superintendent if they
show choose right now the way it's
written they can't because they're
assigned to specific program areas and
those jobs are not open it sounds crazy
but really all we're doing is changing
job titles at the end of the day for the
parks part of it the last part of it is
we did in the budget process request a
second forestry assistant position
and so we got that in the budget process
it was approved went through all the
budget um cycle with Council um and then
unfortunately we didn't change the
number in the pay ordinance from one to
two so mistake on my part um I'm here to
basically ask councel to go ahead and
approve that change from one position to
two the fiscal there's no fiscal impact
the money is already in the budget we
just have to do that so the auditor's
office will let me hire a second person
so with that I'll entertain any
questions you may
have all right and Elena is my second so
okay and that's uh first of three
readings first thank thank you thank you
thank you uh next is or temporary
ordinance 16-25 an ordinance authorizing
the mayor to Grant 10 permanent
supplemental easements to the high power
uh necessary for the construction excuse
me construction and M maintenance of
electrical facilities and to declare an
emergency coming again from the law
committee and councilman crates please
thank you um a is doing some
transmission line rebuilding through the
city and some of their facilities are on
city property and they need supplemental
easements to uh be able to complete
their job while director Hall is there
anything additional you wanted to add uh
yes just briefly so we aren't completely
through with the easements and
negotiating those um but they started
asking for these back in November um and
our Engineers office has been working
with them to try and determine where the
additional easement area they're going
to add is um and what they're going to
compensate the city for as a result of
that um so we're still working through
that I didn't attach the easements
because it's more than 100 pages and I
figure if anybody wants wants to see
those you're more than welcome to see
those but the engineers office has
already determined that they won't um
you know create any issues with our
facilities and our infrastructure that
our utilities have um so we're just
asking you to start reading these there
will be final versions eventually and
when I get those I'll give those to the
clerk of counsel so that they're on the
record and she can share them with you
or any member of the public who wishes
to see them thanks thank
you uh Mr wolfinger you'll be my second
this will go through three readings I
certainly will be and next item is
temporary ordinance
17-25 and we have a guest here to
participate and I'll just defer to uh
law director Hall rather than reading
the whole thing yeah thank you um so
Stephanie did you want to start here or
did you want me to have Caleb
start let's have Caleb start that's why
he gets paid the big bucks okay
everybody I'd like to introduce Mr Caleb
Bell at bicker Gren he is our outside
Economic Development Council and he is
an expert um in this area so all of the
questions that you know you have coming
with regard to this legislation or
really anything that the city is doing
um Economic Development related um would
be good for Caleb so I'll just let you
start thank you Stephanie and um I
believe we're speaking on 17-25 correct
okay very good um so 17-25 is an
ordinance that starts a process the
process that this ordinance starts is a
process that will culminate if all of
the steps are taken uh with an exemption
on Real Property uh called a tiff
exemption that Tiff exemption would
relate to residentially taxed real
property so think of single family homes
this is different than commercial
properties where we have Logistics
facilities or manufacturing there's a
whole different code section that deals
with the commercial stuff here we're
focused on the single family and because
single family uh involves residents and
people who live in homes the general
assembly treats that area in a special
way um the general assembly does a few
things it requires a little bit more
process it requires uh eventually a
hearing uh by this Council uh to
establish an uh it requires uh some
notifications to property owners that
are in the surrounding area um so the
general assembly is kind of you know
doing these things because of just a
higher level of scrutiny um associated
with residential
property also underneath these laws um
the Tiff statutes allow for uh certain
property tax millage to go into an
infrastructure bucket not all millage
goes there when it's residential uh
because the county uh has a number of
Social Service Levy agencies that need
some money for some of those Social
Service needs so the statutes again are
very different than in the commercial
world world where we might have bigger
exemptions or broader exemptions it's a
little more narrowly tailored in the
residential area this specific ordinance
uh what it does is it it focuses in on
the uh Powers Run area um this will be
developed by uh a um a development group
called fourstar and what they're doing
is they're essentially looking at their
development plan and they're saying we
have multiple phases of development that
will come
forward an inefficient result when
you're doing economic planning would be
let's just do everything all at once but
the problem with that in the Home
Building world is that all those homes
all those lots won't be built in the
same year they might be built over two
or two and a half or three years and so
phasing is typically how a residential
home builder deals with uh that reality
similarly on the economic side we want
to do the same thing for the city's
exemption it will provide the closest
tracking to the home building activity
so this legislation calls out five
different incentive districts because
we're trying to track the five different
growth areas within that subdivision um
it's again the most efficient way to
deal with creating this type of
exemption uh so those are the kind of
key points um there is a uh
um again a couple other elements that
are that are in this uh specific spefic
preliminary legislation um an economic
development plan is in the legislation
that's specific to this residential
Development Area again that's an element
of the law basically the general
assembly wants communities like like you
all to decare that there is insufficient
infrastructure in that area and if you
think about it in order to house that
many homes we would need some roads we
would need some internal uh improvements
and with no roads present it's a pretty
straightforward conclusion that we don't
have the necessary infrastructure in
that specific area this isn't a decision
about the Citywide it's really just
about that specific area um and then
finally like I said there are elements
of this process a hearing needs to be
scheduled uh for a little later on the
way that the general assembly likes to
uh you know put these requirements into
the into the community's hands they
would like you all to hear from the
residents prior to an exemption of
course you would do so of course you
have multiple readings of legislation uh
the general assembly is just asking you
to have a specific hearing on this on on
these uh on these exemptions a little
bit later on in the
process following this piece of
legislation it it really needs to go
into effect for us to do the second
thing which is actually establish the
exemption on the
ground there's a lot of process with
these types of exemptions essentially
general assembly is is putting in place
a policy that says you need to be
telling everybody you should be telling
the schools and telling the county and
telling the affected property owners
that there's a residential exemption
that's coming that's good government and
it's also explaining to everybody you
know what's coming in when once all
those notices go then city council has
the authorization to actually uh file an
exemption and and authorize an exemption
so this legislation doesn't do step two
it just does step one kind of lays the
framework and and and follows the
statutes so that then you can do step
two a little on down the road which is
adopt those exemptions so that's
thumbnail sketch of what we have in
front of us uh but I'm happy to answer
any questions about um this or if
there's development questions we can
certainly uh speak with Miss
bosow questions from the committee
everybody
understands it's going to
work I have a question about the devel
part of things sure is this the time for
that I was reading through the uh some
of the literature that we've been given
on this development and I saw patio
homes
listed and my understanding of patio
homes are that they are attached homes
are we is there any place where we're
looking at attached homes here okay no
these are all freestanding single family
homes okay and also I saw on here that
states that the general ordinances and
ordinances of the city of lanter shall
apply except as otherwise provided
within this exhibit and I didn't see any
place where there was a
specific ordinance or anything that was
uh where this project would not
comply I don't think there's anything
specifically with regard to it not
complying I think it's a question of
like our development agreement with them
and if we agree to do something
different than we would normally do um
you know out of the out of the regular
what the code requires um but other than
that there's nothing that we know of
right now um that will that will trigger
that
okay that's all I had thanks why suspend
why are we why are you asking us to
suspend on this we're trying to oh you
go you go I'm sorry um it's a timing
issue so um as Caleb was talking about
the process you know first you know you
have a second reading on um what is
that 1325 tonight um and that's the
ordinance authorizing the execution and
delivery of a petition to establish the
Lancaster new community Authority
District under Ohio code chapter 349 so
we started with that and then there's
like you said very specific timing
things that we have to do along the way
there's got to be 30 days between the
passing of the ordinance and the public
hearing there's got to be 30 days days
um notice to the folks before the public
hearing So based on the timing and when
the developer wants to close in order to
get all of this done um we need to do
one reading for this piece right now and
again this is not this is not
establishing anything this is not
finalizing anything this is just that
first piece in the process like he
explained
okay thank you you're
welcome so my question would be the cost
to the city
and the citizens for this to be done
we're going to have underwriting cost
we're going to have legal cost Caleb
sorry about that and I don't know
whether the city is going to be
responsible for the burden of covering
notes or they going to be in part as
part of the Port Authority
or i' like to know what's coming sure
for a budgetary purposes yeah makes
makes good sense so there's there's a
number of uh pieces uh when a
development comes together like this um
as as you all know what the developer is
asking for
is that the port authority issue a
revenue bond that is secured with these
Tiff dollars so basically create the
Tiff area future Revenue the Tiff
payments will come in over time but in
order to do the work today we need cash
in our hands and so the bond is a way to
seek an investor and get that cash UPF
front in our hands and get the project
done um so commensurate with a bond you
would have underwriting Financial
advisory closing costs legal costs U the
developer has costs for their people uh
Etc um so it's typically the case that
in a revenue bond issue like this the
costs are three to 5% of the total
amount of the of the financing not
unlike getting a bank loan and having
certain origination type
costs that is part of paying for
financing um who's responsible well the
developer is going to as part of the
bond amount borrow to pay for all of
these closing costs the costs of again
Legal Financial it's embedded into the
bond it's embedded in the bond what
happens is over time as those Tiff
payments come in they knock off the bond
and so the Tiff payments are advertising
paying off all the on the bond so in a
way the service payments from this site
only will essentially pay for these
upfront costs including the 3 to 5% of
cost of issuance so there's no
out-of-pocket you know kind of check so
to speak written to close the bonds um I
certainly have you know worked with
Stephanie on and Stephanie on
structuring some of these things very
early on and the city has paid for some
legal bills those are reimbursable if
needed um so pretty much
all of this attendant activity it boils
down to the payments on that site and
it's there's not really a general
promise of the city in any respect to
either repay the bond or pay those types
of costs um and so that's and that's
fairly customary for a tiff
transaction there there is also um I
would say a little bit of administrative
burden a little bit of hurdle uh inside
the city auditor's office and the county
auditor's office to think about how do
you administer Tiff once you start
having a number of parcels you're going
to have a lot of little mini tiffs that
are out there so as your team has I'm
sure uh understanding from their own
knowledge and spoken with others
understand that there's a little bit of
work that's done there part of uh the
setup is to ensure that the auditor team
has professional support that is funded
with these service payments so that and
it's I I think it's like I forget what
the number is 5,00 a year yeah I think
it's 5,000 a year uh to help just
connect the dots track and make sure
that City Auditors team and the county
auditor team are on the same page
because that's where the technical of
all this can get a little uh strange so
we try to care for all those things
right and I appreciate that I want
Council to understand that we're not
writing check today for your fees
correct or anything else it's going to
be wrapped into the bond if it if it
does materialize and does happen I would
ask from the auditor's
perspective um this is a little bit
different than timbertop as far as the
number of parcels correct you got maybe
seven parcels and you're going to have
333 Parcels correct potentially yes and
you'll need additional Revenue if you
thought about that no to be reimbursed
for your time well this is what is
wrapped up where he's talking about
5,000 and hopefully to be able to have
an outside consultant assist with the
keeping track of that because it it will
um put if we had to do inhouse it would
create a burden to do that exactly and
that's why I'm saying it might it'll
probably cost more with this project
than Timberton yes so don't lose
perspective that we need to be made
whole if you will absolutely I think
it's an important part of the city's
overall uh Tiff program um you have
multiple tiffs of multiple different
types overall it's important to ensure
that first and foremost you have to
operate City aor needs everything that
they need part of our job as
professionals is to either do it in
consultation or to help get it uh and
certainly we're we're trying to track
those admin including extraordinary
admin if there's something like a
delinquency that happens and we need to
do a little bit more work you know I'm
not saying we personally I'm saying the
auditor staff the city staff needs to do
some more work you'd need to uh have
have a bucket or a button to push to go
get it um so we tried to think about
those things in our
document any additional Clarity needed
by Council cuz you're right it's one
it's a suspension going forward uh
tonight and uh more to come and I'm sure
you'll be back uh as this gets a little
deeper into the weeds happy to we
appreciate
that okay
um and that
is I who's second and third Mr Wing is
my second and
okay you never all okay to suspect
perfect thank you very much and thank
you appreciate it you information pardon
me you want information on
NCA well someone has questions I thought
I didn't no one's asked me about them so
no that's fine and and I can answer
those if you do but I mean the email
that you sent out with all the questions
I I answered all of those originally so
I think we're good that's why I kind of
wanted everybody to ask questions on
good deal that's clar's mud I think
we're good kale thank you thank you very
much thanks
mayor um now we're moving one more
temporary resolution
18-25 an ordinance authorizing the mayor
to accept an an amended deed of
permanent easement for underground
utility facilities and to declare an
emergency uh again coming from the Law
Department you've been busy tonight I
know
um this legislation will allow the city
to accept a natur natural gas easement
um law director Hall did you want to
give us a little more information on
that yeah I did include the easement
documents in this um specific case
because there is a document um that was
originally recorded um it kind of got a
little messy though after the fact and
the easement area changed and mind you
this easement is being given to the city
um specifically for a gas line by an
individual who's developing properties
out off of country club uh drive he
wanted the those properties to have the
benefit of natural gas provided by the
city and so he is asking us to put this
easement through his property it also
serves the city in that it'll create
some redundancy um and then also new
users who are outside of the city and
therefore can be build as a result um
but the the lineup was not exactly
correct um honestly it's moved fet um
One Direction from the other don't ask
me you know which east to west north to
south I don't know but um it is
literally just moved feet based on the
new engineering um and surveying work
that was done and so we're going back
and we're going to have to kind of fix
all of that at this point um we're
asking for two readings because the uh
private property owner does have the
property for sale he is trying to sell
off residential lots and he would like
to be able to say that those lots are
currently served by Lancaster Municipal
gas um and they already have you know
all of the equipment all of the design
and Engineering marshaled out there um
ready to go so we just need to get this
recorded So that that can take place
thank you thank
you uh Mr wolfing are you on my second
I'll be happy
[Music]
too all righty um any departmental
updates fire chief please come on up yes
sir
good evening members of the council um
I'm here before you tonight just to give
you an advanced notice I plan on
bringing legislation back for your
consideration of the next meeting it is
time for the lens of fire department to
replace one of our fire engines uh my
team's been working through a lot of bid
specs um a lot of different proposals um
just waiting on a couple more small
pieces of information so we make a
better informed decision on financing um
and I'll have more information at the
next meeting to answer any of your
questions that you may have thank you
and apparently no questions anybody else
wants to come up and
speak oh yes he's our new fire chief we
didn't announce that on Council we
didn't announce that he's our new fire
chief Slade Schultz yeah I appreciate
that very much so um we had a a very
nice ceremony was very well attended uh
last week I was promoted to fire chief
uh Larry Moore is promoted to assistant
fire chief um Josh Harris was promoted
to Battalion Chief and Taylor Smith was
promoted to Lieutenant so we appreciate
everybody support and everybody who came
out for that special day for all of
us
great and I believe we determined no one
else wanted to speak under departmental
updates I will now defer to uh president
Porter for tonight's meeting for thank
you chairman
wolfinger this evening we do have a
special presentation by our U late well
I don't want to say late and great
because he's still around but Dr David
our former president he's here to be
he's going to be speaking to us tonight
uh regarding um the board of
Developmental Disabilities and I can
only presume you're going to be speaking
about the levy that's coming up is that
correct not me okay maybe not but uh so
that's that's our special special
presentation this
evening okay I have no other items for
uh finance committee I would entertain a
motion to uh close the meeting so moved
second
second um finance committee is closed
thank you thank you we will begin um the
Lancaster City council meeting a regular
agenda at 6:40
[Music]
the Frankie Smith Funeral Home in
cremator in Lancaster and the Johnson
Smith Funeral Home in Baltimore have a
long and wonderful history of serving
our community feel free to give us a
call at
74653 652 stop in and see us at either
of our two locations 405 North Columbus
Street in Lancaster and and 207 South
Main Street in Baltimore respect for
tradition regard for
[Music]
change hi I'm David O with the Fairfield
County Board of Developmental
Disabilities as many of you know we're
here to help bring about a Vibrant
Community where people lead lives of
Greater Independence and make meaningful
contributions we're truly blessed to
have local supporters like Buckeye
Toyota and Buckeye Honda to once again
make a donation with each car sold this
month through the Buckeye cares program
please support the generous local
business that helps reinforce our
community and just like me you'll be
saying that's how I Buck ey
[Music]
e
e e
[Music]
rise if you're able and join us in a
moment of Prayer
God grant us the serenity to accept the
things that we cannot change the courage
to change the things we can and finally
the wisdom to know the difference I call
the Lancaster City council meeting uh
for March 10th to order please join me
in the Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge alance to the flag
of the United States of America and to
the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible liberty and
justice for
all please call the RO Mr Al here Mr
bisj here Mrs C here Mrs
hoop this
whoop here I'm sorry Mr lenberg I'm here
here Mr skover here Mr Su here miss
tener here Mr Wing here and Mr wolfinger
here please let the record reflect that
all 10 members of Lancaster City Council
are present uh just a housekeeping
reminder please turn on your mics and
make sure you project into them so we
don't get any text messages uh during
the course of the meeting and we'll now
go with the reading and disposing of the
journal regular meeting minutes dated to
February 24th
2025 Mr President I'd like to make a
motion to receive and follow the journal
second we have a motion in a second to
receive and file the journal all those
in favor please signify by by saying I I
all those oppose same sign we'll now
move to the reports of City officials
email dated February 26 2025 regarding
fourstar NCA Revenue projections and
information submitted by law director
Hall emao dated March 3rd 2025 regarding
webinar for Hot Topic uh for Ohio
political subdivisions in 2025 Housing
Development submitted by law director
Hall email dated March 3rd 2025
regarding construction work at Rising
Park submitted by superintendent Gill
email dat of March 4th 2025 regarding
March Planning Commission meeting
submitted by city planner Carter um
email dated March 4th 2025 regarding one
Ohio region 18 2024 Grant cycle fact
sheet submitted by law director Hall
email dated March 6 2025 regarding
February income tax collections reports
submitted by Income Tax Commissioner
Hamilton email dated March 7th 2025
regarding gas rate increases effective
March 1st 2025 submitted by service
safety director Woody email dated March
7th 2025 regarding lanaster transmission
rebuild easements submitted by law
director Hall email dated March 7th 2025
regarding a response to Mr Timothy ke
regarding insufficient notice to
customers of rate incre increases in
utility costs submitted by law director
Hall series of emails um between Mr bisj
Mr wolfinger Mr ALS dated on March 7th
8th and 9th 2025 regarding open Office
hours meet and
great Mr President I'd like to make a
motion to receive and file the reports
of City officials second we have a
motion and second to receive and file
the reports of City officials all those
in favor please signify by saying I I I
all those oppose same sign we now move
to Communications email dated February
27th 2025 regarding public records
requests for National for National
Database of tobacco marijuana control
laws submitted by Mary Pierce with
American non-smokers right foundation
email dat of March 6 20125 regarding
Central Ohio 2024 housing starts lag
demand press release submitted by
Stephanie OB Bosco with Port Authority
email dat of March 10th 2025 regarding
public records request on HVAC
preventative maintenance contract
submitted by Bobby Brady with GTC
Mechanical
Services Mr President I'd like to make a
motion to receive and file the
communications second we have a motion
and a second to receive and file the
communications all those in favor please
signify by saying I I all those oppose
same sign we will now move to special
presentations uh and this evening we
have uh Dr David O with the Fairfield
County Board of Developmental
Disabilities welcome back Dr
o well good evening Mr President members
of council it's good to see some
colleagues around the table and uh it's
really good to be on this side of the
podium so uh I'm glad to be back and to
be with you all tonight I want to spend
a little bit of time talking about the
Fairfield County Board of Developmental
Disabilities marches developmental
disabilities Awareness Month and we are
out and about across our community
ensuring that we are advocating and
educating and informing people about
Fairfield DED and the people we support
uh I've given this presentation several
times already this month I have it down
to a Brisk 37 minutes so let's move
ahead I'd like for you I'm just kidding
Mr alss I'm kidding it's
okay I'd like for you to imagine with me
if you would a young man who's
graduating from high school and like
many has a dream and a goal of going to
college and not going to college
necessarily anywhere near home but like
many wants to travel far from home to be
independent and on his own in order to
transition into adulthood and yet this
young man's disabilities caused
significant challenges for him as he
works to find the right supports from
providers to fulfill his educational
dreams with the support of Fairfield DD
this young man contacted more than 40
different providers before finally
securing uring reliable support he took
the initiative to advocate for himself
with those providers and to train those
providers in an effort to ensure that
they were going to be able to meet his
needs now enrolled in college far from
home he's well on his way to fulfilling
his educational dreams and living a more
independent life think about a younger
child 9 years old a young boy who's full
of life and enjoys hockey and riding his
go-kart outdoors and yet he often runs
into barriers at home because he has a
short stature in fact he doesn't have
legs and so he is often times finding it
difficult to do the very common things
that you and I would be able to do carry
something from one room to the next or
turn on a light switch as an example of
something that he can't reach and so if
he would want to move from one room to
the next he would go in there and if he
was unable to get to the light switch he
would either depend on someone from his
family to turn the light on or he would
sit in the room in the dark with
Fairfield D's help our assistive and
enabling technology coordinator was able
to provide a great number of lowtech
inexpensive solutions to help this young
boy out we installed motion lights in
his closet so that when he goes in and
out they simply come on and off we
installed smart bulbs throughout his
room so that all he has to do is use his
voice in order to turn the lights on or
to change the colors of the lights and
Amazon Alexa plays his favorite music
now he has simple tools he can use to
carry something from one room to the
next all of these things impossible
without the assistance of Fairfield DD
and our assist of Technology work with
him but now JB has the opportunity to
live with more Independence using these
relatively low tag and inexpensive
Solutions these are two stories of
hundreds and hundreds that we currently
work with at the Fairfield County Board
of Developmental Disabilities our
mission at Fairfield Ed is simple we
exist to bring about a Vibrant Community
where people lead lives of Greater
Independence and make meaningful
contributions it is our vision it's our
Dream to build a community that
recognizes the value of each and every
person and right now Fairfield Ed lives
out that out every day we currently
support 1,900 people with disabilities
in Fairfield County and if you were to
just think 10 years ago with me that is
an increase of
60% when I started at the County Board
13 or so years ago we were in the
hundreds it was 7 or 800 people
supported and then just 10 years ago
1,180 and now 1900 nearly 2,000 people
in the next 5 years we expect that we
will be supporting more than 3,000
people with disabilities here in
Fairfield County and I'm not telling you
anything you don't know as city leaders
Fairfield County has been since 2010 and
Remains the fifth fastest growing county
in the state and as the county grows and
as people come here to work and live the
need for services continues to grow
exponentially some of the services that
we offer that you may be familiar with
include early intervention Serv Services
these are our birth to three-year-old
services that we offer to some
438 kids across Fairfield County a 52%
increase from just two years ago as we
were emerging from the pandemic our
developmental Specialists and therapists
work in the home with zero to
three-year-old students kids to help the
parents in their natural environment
address any developmental delays that
that kid may have
the goal is to reduce or eliminate those
developmental delays so that the child
may not even have need for DD services
in the future our investment now as they
are in the very early and formative
years of their life pays off dividends
both for them and their ability to live
more independently and for the County
Board as we go forward it is certainly
an investment that is worthwhile many of
you may be familiar with Forest row
school out on State Route 37 Forest row
School
is a school for students who have
significant medical uh involvement with
regards to their disability kids who
cannot be served in their home school
district we have Partnerships with all
eight districts in Fairfield County and
we have students from Seven of those
eight districts attending Forest row
right now we have a preschool class that
is integrated both with kids with and
without disabilities we also have school
age from kindergarten through 12th grade
of kids only with disabilities and when
you think of medically involved kids
what we're talking about are kids with a
G tube or a j tube maybe they have a tra
that needs cleaned out multiple times a
day maybe they have medications that
need passed throughout the day multiple
times perhaps they have hygiene needs
throughout the day our team of educators
of AIDS and of therapists work to
provide service to those students in
places and times when their school
district is unable to and we offer all
types of therapy we have music therapy
speech therapy occupational therapy
physical therapy and uh one of the
things that everyone is always most
excited about is is water therapy we do
have a pool at Forest row school it's 2
feet deep and always 88 degrees I've
never been in it just in case anyone's
interested but uh it is a huge asset to
our students when when you see a kid
who's all bound up because of their
disability physically and you put them
in that warm water and they begin to
loosen and move it's just an
unbelievable thing to experience and so
Forest R School continues to exist um to
support those students who have the
greatest need in our communities and
we're working on that every single day
many of you are familiar with our social
Enterprises downtown V and Clay Main in
square 7 Coffee House these are
integrated work settings we employ uh
diverse Workforce of people with and
without disabilities at Art and Clay we
have internships available for students
who may be in special ed classes at
Lancaster High School we have
opportunities for people to come and
learn work skills so again they can work
in their community and be more
independent as they live in their
Community one of the greatest uh and and
I guess the most expansive services that
we offer is Service Coordination this is
a shift from several years ago where the
County Board was involved in a number of
Direct Services I just mentioned a few
of the Direct Services that we have
right now they're generally uh geared
toward children but we don't offer
direct service for adults any longer we
rely on a provider pool of professionals
to provide the care and support that
people need what we do is coordinate and
fund that support that is what we're
mandated to do by Ohio Revis code we
coordinate all the services that people
receive in the community and we fund
those services and so every person who
comes through Fairfield DD is receiving
service either through Service
Coordination connection to the the
community or they're receiving funding
for those
Services one of our values at Fairfield
DED is fiscal responsibility and as you
think about our budget and our expenses
71% of our expenditures are directly
related to serving and supporting people
with developmental disabilities in the
community and some may say oh well that
overhead seems high but the reality is
is that our people are our service we're
funding and providing a service through
coordination and so it takes people to
do that it takes teachers and AIDS and
therapists and case workers in order to
provide that support 71% of those
expenditures directly related to
supporting people and 75% of our staff
members are directly involved in
providing that support to people now
when you look at the expense side of
things or the revenue side of things uh
it you you see that we are property tax
funded put some reports around the table
it's our annual impact report and you
can see these numbers 77% of our annual
revenue is derived from property tax
that is the system that we live in in
Ohio all 88 counties must have a County
Board and all 88 Counties have property
tax levies in order to support those
County Boards of Developmental
Disabilities and we can't say thank you
enough to the Fairfield County taxpayers
who have entrusted us with dollars over
the years um but as we look at our
revenue and
expense the reality is is that uh we are
at the end of a 10-year term Levy and so
this is not a uh example or a situation
where oh we've overspent we we don't
need Doge to come in and and and do a
review because we haven't been wise with
taxpayer dollars what's happened is the
levy is simply ending it was 10 years it
was passed in 2015 the math is easy it
ends this year this Levy accounts for
one third of our operating revenue and
so its renewal is vital now I am not
permitted to attempt to persuade you
miss Hall's going to do that in just a
moment because she's on our Levy
committee but what I am permitted to do
as the superintendent of Fairfield Ed is
provide factual objective information
about the levy we are on the ballot for
a 5-year renewal 1.85 mil property tax
levy what this means for the property
taxpayer of Fairfield County because it
is a renewal is that it is no new taxes
no additional taxes for you your
property tax if you were to vote Yes on
this Levy would not increase one penny
in 2026 or in the preceding five years
that the levy has turned for and you say
how's this possible it can be possible
my property taxes have have gone up my
property value has gone up this is a
simple renewal on the 2015 rates based
on what your property was valuated at at
that time we are not replacing this we
are not asking for more money it is a
simple renewal that will cost zero
pennies more for every single property
taxpayer in Fairfield County uh and when
you want if you want to do the math it's
about $40 per $100,000 valuation for
every property taxpayer and as I
mentioned generates about a third of our
budget we are not a small organization
we are a large organization nearly 165
team members again supporting 2,000
people and their families with about a
$23 million annual budget so $7.6
million is is what this Levy will
generate for us and uh someone asked in
one of my other meetings well what would
happen if it didn't pass Fairfield DD
because we've been good stewards of
taxpayer dollars is able to do a simple
renewal and use the same dollar that we
were getting in 2015 clear through 2030
and continue to support people
throughout that 5year period if the levy
were not to pass the simple truth is
Services would be impacted think of a
third of a cut to your budget uh for the
city what what would happen Services
would be cut people would be laid off uh
and for us uh needed services for people
with disabilities would not only be cut
but our weight list would explode we
currently have a zero weight list we
provide service and support to everyone
who has a need as they come through and
have zero people on our weight list if
this Levy were not to pass that would
not be the case for us and so uh I'll
leave leave you with with that and and
the fact that everything that we do at
Fairfield Ed flows out of our mission to
work toward a more inclusive community
to work to ensure that everyone has the
ability to belong in and to their
community so that they can live and work
and play and worship and do whatever it
is they want as independently as
possible not completely independent
because none of us is certainly I am not
completely independent Miss Hall will
tell you that is true however uh I uh
know that and believe that every person
can take steps toward greater
Independence every single day and that's
what we're working on uh I'm thankful to
the city as I wrap up the city is a
great partner various departments
whether it be the mayor's Department um
in his office the law director's office
uh whether it be uh parks and wreck that
we have a great relationship with um uh
City Planning we're working on some of
the accessibility stuff with City
Planning that you all are doing right
now uh we have a very important and Rich
partnership and I'm grateful for that uh
with that I'll pause to see if there are
any questions before I ask Miss Hall to
do her
thing you're
good we're good okay so I appreciate
everybody um being here and listening
and paying attention and I would really
appreciate it if everybody would take
this information back to their
constituents um your friends your family
you know all of the Fairfield County
property taxpayers that you know and let
them know that this is a really really
important Levy um that we need to see
pass in May um so David kind of told you
what um Fairfield DD does um and I'm
here to tell you what they need in order
to do that and what they need is this
Levy money um he prepared a pitch for me
he uh actually stole about two-thirds of
it so um I'm just going to give you a
little more information um but then
happy to answer any questions at the end
as well so May 6 2025 that is when
Ohio's primary election date will be
this year voters in Fairfield County are
going to be asked to renew the current
1.85 mil property tax levy for the
Fairfield County Board of Developmental
Disabilities the renewal will not
increase your tax rates a single penny
and that has to be you know said over
and over and over again because
obviously that is the big sell right we
want to continue to provide these
services and not increase taxes so
that's
fantastic and it's needed the money is
needed to maintain support for services
to individuals with developmental
disabilities and operations at the
Forest Rose school to put it simply
Fairfield DD needs the funding to serve
people in our community who have
developmental disabilities and I can
just attest in my role as law director
and City prosecutor we work with a lot
of the clients that David serves um
Fairfield DD serves a lot of folks who
both end up as you know defendants and
victims unfortunately um we work very
closely with their major incident
investigators to make sure sure that um
you know their their victims are treated
um with the same you know respect and
appropriate um involvement in the
process as anybody else and just the
seeing firsthand the care and the
compassion and the commitment that they
have um to the clients that they serve
as they go through the criminal justice
system um it's it's overwhelming
sometimes and definitely really
appreciated um so funding for the
renewal will enable them to continue to
provide those types of you know support
um learning opportunities and Community
enhancement um and connections for
individuals with developmental
disabilities and help lead them towards
greater Independence and that's that's
the theme um Fairfield DD is increasing
Independence and not taxes and so I
would urge everybody um those watching
at home those in the audience and
everybody around the table tonight to
vote Yes on May 6th for the Fairfield DD
Levy and if you would like to support
the levy like I have um David's provided
me with a levy endorsement sign up um I
believe Clerk of Court Brandon Meyer has
signed up on this one and he is the only
one I signed up on an earlier sheet but
I'm going to pass it around so that if
anybody would like to sign in order to
um provide your endorsement and um you
know permit the board and the levy
committee to use that moving forward
we'd really appreciate it thank
you are there any questions from Council
Members based upon Dr 's uh presentation
and that of law director
Hall hearing none I would just convey
council's sincere appreciation for the
work that the board is doing in the
community and we thank you for tonight's
presentation thank you for the
opportunity thank
you we'll now move back into the agenda
with petitions and memorials there are
no petitions oops sorry there are no
petitions or memorials this evening
thank you we have now reached the time
in the agenda for the permission of
Voters and taxpayers to address council
is there anybody here this evening that
would like to address councel if so I'm
going to go through the rules briefly I
know that some of you have already
spoken before but you have three minutes
to address Council you sign up uh you
give your name and address on the list
and um you make your address directly to
council it's not a question and answer
period and you don't address members of
the audience thank
you thank you so um this wasn't planned
it actually just worked out but um my
son is um autistic and so we have
dealings with developmental disabilities
and I actually run a parent group for
parents and providers for children with
developmental disabilities and I reached
out um sort of on a wh to FAO County
Sheriff's Office and to l police
department and I got a response right
away from officer Sims from ler Police
Department because I
wanted the intent was that my child
specifically but I know if it's my child
that others can benefit too um would
have some exposure and see the police in
a positive light so that maybe you don't
deal with them later on um because he
doesn't respond to other people right so
he responds to me I can tell him to sit
or even you know put your hands in the
air or get hands well whatever it is not
not like I'm doing that all the time but
I can tell him to do something and he'll
do it a police officer can ask him to do
the same thing and he won't do it and so
the hope is is that we have a
conversation he sees them in a positive
atmosphere and image and light and
perhaps they learned something from my
son my son maybe learned something from
them and we don't have cuz you know when
you're in an
emergency in my War spere we're in an
accident and I can't be there to help
them he needs to be able to respond
hopefully and if he's not able to
respond hopefully they can then take the
training and this is kind of gives them
some onhand training of dealing with
somebody like him so I've had a lot of
positive feedback it's going to be March
26th um 5:00 at the police department
but uh kudos to LPD for signing up
getting back to me right away and saying
yes let's do this so that's all I want
to say thank
you is there anybody else who would like
to address Lancaster City Council this
evening hearing none uh we thank you for
coming and attending tonight's meeting
we now move to the reports of standing
committees we have finance committee
meeting minutes dated February 24 2025
submitted by Mr wolfinger service
committee agenda dated Mar Mar 7th 2025
submitted by Mr ALS finance committee
agenda dated March 8th 2025 submitted by
Mr
wolfinger Mr President I'd like to make
a motion to receive and file the reports
of standing committees second we have a
motion a second to receive and file the
reports of standing committees all those
in favor please signify by I all those
oppose same sign we have no public
hearings this evening which means we
will be moving into the reading of
resolutions beginning with the third
reading of temporary resolution
17-25 a resolution authorizing the
service safety director to advertise for
bids and enter into a contract for the
construction of a maintenance and
storage facility for use by the
Lancaster fire department and to declare
an emergency this is through uh s Safety
Committee Mr bisj and Mr Sully council
member bisj thank you Mr President I
move that Council pass and engross and
enter upon the written record resolution
temporarily numbered $17
-25 second we have a motion and second
to pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary resolution
1725 um discussion council member bisj
thank you Mr President uh once again
just want to remind Council that this is
a legislation authorizing the safety
service director to go out for bid uh
for the purpose of building a
maintenance and storage facility for the
fire uh Department this will be
specifically going to the engine uh
around Engine House 3 behind Engine
House 3 uh just a place to store
equipment as well as store fired uh
engines and perform basic maintenance so
that's all I have Mr President thank you
thank you any further discussion from
other council members hearing none
please call the role Mr ALS yes Mr bisj
yes Mrs KES yes Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg
yes Mr skover yes Mr Sully yes Miss
tener yes Mr Wing yes and Mr wolfinger
yes temporary resolution 17725 passes 10
to zero that concludes reading third
reading of U resolutions we move to the
second readings beginning with temporary
resolution
20-25 a resolution to authorize the
service safety director to dispense with
competitive bidding and enter into a
contract to with Montrose Ford for the
purchase of four police vehicles for use
by the Lancaster Police Department this
is again through Safety Committee Mr
bisj and Miss tener council member bisj
thank you Mr President this will be the
second of three readings second of three
readings on temporary res resolution
2025 temporary resolution
21-25 a resolution to appropriate from
the unencumbered balance and Amed the
certificate with the county auditor in
the general fund
10001 Safety Committee um again Mr bisj
and Mr Sully council member bisj thank
you Mr President this will be the second
of three readings second of three
readings on temporary resolution
21-25 temporary resolution
23-25 a resolution to appropriate from
the UN incomer balance in the cemetery
Perpetual care fund
8034 complete a fund transfer increase
receipts and Appropriations in the
cemetery fund
20007 and amend their certificate of
other sources and Appropriations with
the county auditor this is through
Public Works committee um Miss Tiner and
Mr lenberg council member tener second
of three readings second of three
readings on temporary resolution
2325 temporary resolution
24-25 a resolution to authorize the
service safety director to dispense with
a competitive bidding for a so s Soul
Source provider for corrosion Inhibitors
um this through water water pollution
committee Mr Wing and Miss tener council
member Wing this is the second of three
readings second of three readings on
temporary resolution
24-25 temporary resolution
25-25 a resolution to authorize the
service safety director to advertise for
bids and enter into a contract for the
city hall renovation project this is
through finance committee Mr wolfinger
Mr Sully council member wolfinger second
of three readings second of three
readings on temporary resolution
25-25 now move on to First reading of
resolutions beginning with temporary
resolution
2625 a resolution authorizing the
Lancaster tree commission to apply for
the Ohio Department of Natural Resources
urban forestry Grant and to declare an
emergency this is through service
committee Mr alss and Mr Wing council
member alss first of two readings please
first of two readings on temporary
resolution
2625 temporary resolution
27-25 a resolution authorizing the city
law director's office to apply for the
violence against women act Grant this is
through law committee Mrs Kites and Mr
bisj council member kites first of three
readings please first of three readings
on temporary resolution
27-25 that concl concludes the reading
of resolutions for this evening's
meeting we now move on to the reading of
ordinances beginning with the third
reading of temporary ordinance
9-25 an ordinance to appeal and replace
Lancaster codified ordinance part n
streets utility and public services code
chapter 937 waste removal this is
through service committee Mr ALS and Mrs
hoop council member alss uh yes I move
that we pass and engross and enter upon
the written record ordinance temp early
numbered
9-25 a second we have a motion a second
to pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary ordinance
9-25 discussion council member ALS well
probably the most important thing that
you need to remember is that people that
have used that have dumped at the U yard
way stump for free for a number of years
are now going to be charged for it so
you might get a phone call but there's a
good reason for it so uh I support this
thank you any further discussion from
councel hearing none please call the
rooll Mr ALS yes Mr bisek yes Mrs craes
yes Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr
skover yes Mr Su yes Miss tener yes Mr
Wing yes Mr wolfinger yes temporary
ordinance 9-25 passes 10 to Zer
temporary ordinance 12-25 was withdrawn
and has been replaced with temporary or
excuse me temporary ordinance 12-25 had
been withdrawn temporary ordinance
12-25 star um was in its place
yes an ordinance authorizing the exe
execution and delivery of an a
Cooperative agreement among the
Lancaster Port Authority the city of
Lancaster Ohio Lancaster development
company LLC and the huntingon national
bank and authorizing the appropriation
of tax increment financing funds for
payment of debt service with respect to
the maximum aggregate principal amount
of $6 million of Port Authority revenue
bonds to be issued to pay cost of public
infrastructure improvements authorizing
the execution and delivery of a tiff
Administration agreement between Argus
growth Consultants Ltd in the city
authorizing and approving related
matters and to declare an emergency
economic devel vment committee Mrs hoop
and Mrs cres council member hoop yes is
it correct that we haven't amended this
yet no we haven't that is correct Mo so
Mr President I would like to make a
motion to replace temporary ordinance
1225 um and replace it with temporary
ordinance 12-25 star second we have a
motion in a second to uh replace
temporary ordinance 12-25 with temporary
ordinance 12-2 2 Star Law director we
don't have to state that this has been
provided in writing prior to tonight's
meeting because we've had it for a bit
right yeah good thank you um any
discussion council member who no not
this time any further discussion from
councel hearing none please call the
role on the motion to replace Mr Al yes
Mr bisack yes Mrs CH yes Mrs hoop yes Mr
lenberg yes Mr SC yes Mr Su yes Miss
tener yes Mr Wing yes and Mr wolfinger
yes motion to replace temporary
ordinance 12-25 with temporary ordinance
12-25 star uh passes 10 to zero council
member who yes um I would like to make a
motion that Council pass and gross and
enter upon the written record temporary
ordinance 12-25 star second we have a
motion of second to pass engross and
enter upon the written record temporary
ordinance 12-25 star any further
discussion council member um no this is
just to update the um
tiff with the Lancaster development
company thank you any further discussion
from Council Members hearing none please
call Mr ALS yes Mr bisack yes Mrs CH yes
Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover
yes Mr Sol yes Miss tener yes Mr Wing
yes and Mr wolfinger yes temporary
ordinance 12- 25 star passes 10 to Zer
we'll now move on to the second reading
of ordinances beginning with temporary
ordinance
13-25 an ordinance authorizing the
execution and delivery of a petition to
establish the Lancaster new community
Authority District under Ohio Revised
Code chapter
349 this is through law committee and
this Mrs crates and Mr bisack council
member crates yes thank you Mr President
I would like to make a motion that
Council suspend its rules and wave the
third reading of resolution sorry
ordinance temporarily number 13-25
second we have a motion in a second to
uh suspend the rules and wave the third
reading of temporary ordinance
13-25 uh council member hoop any
discussion on the motion to
suspend
um there's a a timeline that we are
trying to meet uh to you're good to
create this sorry all right we get it
sometimes did you have a slip of your
lines there you go for the creation of
this new community Authority that we're
trying to meet um and that's why we're
asking for suspension for that third
reading thank you council member kites
any further
discussion hearing none please call the
RO on the motion to suspend Mr ALS yes
Mr bisek yes Mrs K yes Mrs hoop yes Mr
lenberg yes Mr skover yes Mr Sully yes
Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes and Mr
wolfinger yes motion to suspend the rule
and W the third reading of temporary
ordinance 13-25 passes 10 to Z council
member kites thank you Mr President I
would like to make a motion that Council
pass Andross and enter upon the written
record ordinance temporarily number
13-25 second
second we had another line slip there
anyway um
huh all right yeah um so we have a
motion second to pass gross enter upon
the written record uh temporary
ordinance
13-25 any further discussion uh nothing
thank you thank you please call the rle
Mr alss yes Mr bisj yes Mrs C yes Mrs
hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover yes Mr
Sul yes Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes and
Mr wolfinger yes uh temporary ordinance
13-25 passes 10 to Zer we'll now move on
to the first reading of ordinances
beginning with temporary ordinance
14-25 in ordinance approving and Ed the
editing and inclusion of certain or
ordinances as parts of various component
codes of the code ordinances of
Lancaster Ohio and a declar an emergency
so law committee Mr CH and Mr wol
figer council member C thank you Mr
President I would like to make a motion
that Council suspend its rules and wave
the second and third readings of
ordinance temporarily numbered
14-25 second we have a motion second to
suspend rule in wave the second third
reading of temporary ordinance 14-25 any
discussion uh yes the these are code
updates to mirror the codes uh in the
state code and because the laws have
already been passed we want to get this
um updated as soon as possible and
that's why we're asking for suspension
thank you any further discussion on the
motion to suspend hearing none please
call the RO Mr Al Mr bisack Mrs CH Mrs
hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover yes
yes Mr Su yes M tener yes Mr Wing yes
and Mr wolfinger yes temporary or motion
to suspend the rules and wave the second
and third reading of temporary ordinance
14-25 passes 10 to Zer uh council member
hoop or excuse me I did that again
council member FR thank you Mr President
I would like to make a motion that
Council pass and gross and enter upon
the written record ordinance temporarily
number
14-25 second Motion in second to pass
and gross and enter upon the written
record ordinance
14-25 any further discussion uh no it's
just updating the code thank you uh
please call the role Mr ALS Mr bisj Mrs
hoop yes I'm sorry Mrs CH yes Mr
lenberg Mr Mr lenberg yes Mr skover yes
Mr Sully yes Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes
and Mr
wolfinger temporary ordinance
14-25 passes 10 to zero temporary
ordinance
15-25 an ordinance to amend permanent
55-24 also known as The Parks and
Recreation pay ordinance and to declare
an emergency this is through service
committee with Mr ALS and Mrs hoop
council member alss first of three
readings please first of three readings
on temporary ordinance
15-25 temporary ordinance
16-25 an ordinance authorizing the mayor
to Grant 10 permanent supplemental
easements to the Ohio power company
necessary for the construction and
maintenance of electric facilities and
to declare an emergency this is through
um law committee Mrs KES and Mr
wolfinger council member KES first of
three readings please first of three
readings on temporary ordinance
16-25 uh temporary ordinance
17-25 an ordinance delimitating um
overlays in relation to the proposed
Powers Run incentives districts number
one through number five within the city
of Lancaster Ohio adopting a written
economic development plan as to same
setting the time and place of a public
hearing authorizing and ratifying the
giving of notice to the Lancaster City
school district and the board of County
commissioners of fairf for County Ohio
all pursuant to Ohio Revised Code
section
5794 c and it's relates rules related
rules and laws and dispensing with the
requirement that this ordinance must be
read on three different days pursuant to
a higher Revised Code
section
73117 a this is through Economic
Development Committee Mrs hoop and Mr
Wing council member hoop yes Mr
President I would like to make a motion
that Council suspend its rules and wave
the second and third readings of
temporary ordinance
17-25 second have a motion a second to
suspend the rules and wave the second
third reading of temporary ordinance
17-25 any discussion on the motion to
suspend um no Mr Bell was here earlier
in finance and it's just a
complicated yes issue so it needs the
timeliness thank you to be passed any
further discussion from Council Members
hearing none please call the rule Mr ALS
Mr bisack Mrs CR yes Mrs hoop yes Mr
lenberg yes Mr skover yes Mr Sully yes
Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes and Mr
wolfinger yes motion to suspend the
rules and may the second third reading
of temporary ordinance 17-25 pass 10 to
zero uh council member hoop um yes Mr
President I would like to make a motion
that Council pass Andross and enter upon
the written record temporary ordinance
17-25 second we have motion and second
to pass gross and enter upon the written
record temporary ordinance
17-25 any further discuss discuss on
this yes law director Hall I apologize I
just wanted to add I forgot to tell you
earlier this piece is asking you to
ratify that you sent notice to the
Fairfield County uh Board of
Commissioners as well as Lancaster City
schools and I did that on your behalf so
that has been done and I just neglected
to tell you I apologize thank you any
further
discussion hearing none please call the
rooll Mr ALS yes Mr bisj yes Mrs CH yes
Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr G yes Mr
Sul yes Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes and
Mr wolfinger
yes motion
to pass Andross and enter upon the
written record temporary ordinance 17-25
passes 10 to zero temporary ordinance
18-25 an ordinance authorizing the mayor
to accept an amended deed of the
permanent easement for underground
utility facilities and to declare an
emergency this is through law committee
Mrs crates and Mr wolfinger council
member CR first of two readings please
first of two readings on temporary
ordinance
18-25 now move to um tabled legislation
we're not removing that from the table
so that concludes the reading of
legislation for this
evening uh we now move to unfinished
business is there any unfinished
business on behalf of any council
members Mr Mayor did you have anything I
just want to follow up uh our last
meeting regarding City Hall um
Renovations and windows we will have a
presentation for council at the next
meeting with additional information on
that on the windows and our
recommendations Etc thank you any
discussion from Council Members okay
thank you um we now move to new
business council member bisj uh thank
you Mr President I just want to let the
residents of the city and especially the
residents of uh the second W that on
March 22nd it's a Saturday from 2:30 to
4:30 uh on the third third floor of the
Fairfield countyy District Library in
their boardroom I'll be hosting office
hours so if anybody wants to come out
want to work together on something we
can do for the city or you just want to
stop by and say hello I'll be there and
happy to talk so thank you Mr President
thank you yes auditor Nettles I just
wanted to give Council an update on the
next council meeting um City's Bond
Council will bringing debt legislation
for the city hall Renovations which will
go through readings but just to give you
guys a heads up that that'll be coming
on the next meeting thank you auditor
Nettles is there any other new business
from any Council me council member Tiner
I did want to ask questions so kind of
big piggybacking off of what you said
about you're having this meeting so we
got this email from Mr bisek asking for
everybody to be there is that a Sunshine
Law
violation it is a pre-arranged meeting
of more than a majority of the members
of council and you are discussing
Council business
then yes it could be a violation um if
it's more of a just hear what people
have to say and don't promise anything
necessarily or don't really discuss your
position or your ability to you know
assist with the problem um then it's not
it's not really really an issue um the
other problem is the fact that you know
your committees are only made up of
three people sometimes so if there was a
committee that two of you were on for
example um and a member of the public
brought something up that was related to
your committee and there was a
discussion about that then yes that
would be a violation of the open
meetings act um but you know I'm more
than willing to work with councilman
bisj to to find a way that he can do
that and anybody else can do that if
they would like to do it um it's just
you just have to be really careful
because it can get gray really quick
yeah okay
and yes and just to clarify I I did send
out something clarifying that this will
be just strictly a second W event so I
want to make that clear as well just to
avoid any potential issues uh with that
so I did send that out to council and
the law director in the mayor and all of
council so just making that clear thank
you okay because I know the three of you
all met at tar last year and I didn't
know if that was a
violation of Sunshine Law Michael and um
Elena and Joe all met at tar last it's
so I just didn't know I I I think the
Sunshine Law thing is something we need
to take
that's something we that class we need
to take I mean I've taken it every two
years since I've been on Council and
that's what I had mentioned before I
think it's something pretty important
for us to take yeah it's important
enough that it's required by law so I
think people got that so we appreciate
that Insight any further discussion any
uh issues thank you um we'll now move on
to the announcement of scheduled
meetings next regular sessions of counc
ccil is March 24th 2025 at 6:30 here in
City Chambers or council chambers sorry
and then April 7th 2025 at 6:30 p.m.
council
chambers uh special scheduled meetings
there appear to be none now we would
move to regularly scheduled committee
meetings we have Public Works committee
March 14th at 7:30 a.m. in the city hall
1897 conference room water water
pollution control service committee
March 17th at 7:30 a.m. City Hall 1897
conference room Safety
Committee April 4th at 8:00 a.m. the
city hall 1897 room administrative
service committee April 16th at 8:00
a.m. City Hall 1897 conference room code
enforcement and zoning committee April
17th at 7:30 a.m. City Hall 1897
conference room and then economic
development committee meeting um April
24th at 7:30 a.m. in City Hall 1897
conference room thank you reading of
bills um I do have two this evening I
have one from mnco for
8656 and then for perform graphic
Services
$863 62 this is for legislation paper
that I had to order because we were out
and that would be the first order of
legislation paper since
2021 so that's correct there just to put
that into perspective so Mr Mr pres I'd
like to make a motion to pay the bills
second you have a motion second to pay
bills all those in favor please signify
by saying I I I thank you uh no
executive session uh this evening i'
entertain a motion motion to adjourn
second have a motion a second to adjourn
all those in favor signif signify by
saying I I I okay we're adjourned please
remember to sign your legislation before
leaving this evening
[Music]
the Frankie Smith Funeral Home in
cremator in Lancaster and the Johnson
Smith Funeral Home in Baltimore have a
long and wonderful history of serving
our community feel free to give us a
call at
74653 652 stop in and see us at either
of our two locations 405 North Columbus
Street in Lancaster and 207 South Main
Street in Baltimore respect for
tradition regard for change
[Music]
hi I'm David O with the Fairfield County
Board of Developmental Disabilities as
many of you know we're here to help
bring about a Vibrant Community where
people lead lives of Greater
Independence and make meaningful
contributions we're truly blessed to
have local supporters like Buckeye
Toyota and Buckeye Honda to once again
make a donation with each car sold this
month through the Buckeye cares program
please support the generous local
business that helps reinforce our
community and just like me you'll be
saying that's how I Buck
Eye
e e